foreign
is curious about trying to find out what
is true about the world can catcher
gives us the ability to peer inside of
matter and to get at the heart of the
way things actually are
our modern way of life would not be at
all possible without developments that
come from chemistry but it's also
important to note that chemistry has a
real contribution to make to the liberal
arts the history of science is filled
with fascinating stories and I think
oftentimes in science courses that piece
is lost to some extent
we will be looking at the contributions
of Lavoisier and Dalton and Mendeleev
and Lewis we'll be learning about the
development of the periodic table the
structure of the atom the story of the
development of models for atomic
structure and also explain the way in
which a huge variety of compounds can be
made to create the vast diversity and
materials that we see in the world join
me as we explore the fascinating world
of chemistry
I'm Matt young Professor of chemistry at
Hillsdale College
this is our course on chemistry let's
begin
[Laughter]